all right cool let's get it started
hey everyone good morning good morning
how's everyone doing excited to be
adored oh yeah awesome I've been having
a good time too so my name is Prateek I
work on the visual studio product team
at Microsoft how many of y'all use
Visual Studio okay cool I'm in the right
room Visual Studio 2019 anyone all right
a lot of you 2017
okay still some 2015 all right I'm not
gonna ask beyond that but hopefully
hopefully by the end of this talk I'd
have convinced all of you who are not on
2019 to move over to 2019 as fast as you
can
so let's get started
we have a bunch of things to talk about
and I'm gonna it's pretty demo heavy so
I'm going to be showing you a lot of
things as well and some of this stuff
you may have seen in other talks that my
colleagues have given over the last few
months and another blog post as well but
if I'm repeating things that's only
because we get like thousands of new
users that join the family every single
week and I want to get everyone on the
same page so I'm gonna be going going
over some stuff again and also I there's
a great team that I work with and all of
these features have been pushed and
brought into the product by that team
and so I'm just a messenger showing off
all the features that the great features
that and the great work that the team is
done so let's get started with code
fixes and factorings refactorings enable
you to apply code style changes to your
code after after the fact after you're
done coding and so you can code the way
that you want and still conform to your
team standards and in Visual Studio 2019
over the last year we've added hundreds
of new refactorings to to the product
and this is just a few of them that and
I'm gonna show you just a little bit
about because I want to show off these
new features so let's jump into the code
base this is an application called user
sentiment it's it's a demo app that we
have and it it generates sentiment from
users tweets and so it gives you a happy
sad sort of indifferent sentiment and
and while I've been working on this app
been moving around a lot of files
folders refactoring restructuring the
app and so if I move a file into a
folder then I have to go and just like
change the namespace by myself and I
have to do that manually for every time
I do it and so that's it's always
annoying so but now I have this little
screwdriver over here and that's the
quick actions menu so I can hit control
dot or open that and what that does is
if I hit control whoops there we go
I it automatically suggests which folder
structure I'm in and and asked me to
change the namespace so smartly and to
ative Lee tells you which folder I can
move I've moved this file to and suggest
to change the namespace like that so I
can get that change really quickly I
also have a switch statement over here
and it's pretty long and verbose and so
if I hit ctrl dot on the switch
statement I have the ability to convert
that switch statement to a switch
expression and once I do that that code
is a lot more readable and a lot more
compact now and so such expressions are
a feature of c-sharp eight so if you're
using that then you can use switch
expressions which are really cool and
I'm going to jump over to emoji search
and I have some code that I wanted to
write over here and I'm gonna continue
writing that and what I want to show you
is I need to use this method
Jason convert and it's giving me the
intellisense for the suggestion for this
jason convert method which is in the
newton soft jason library but if I go up
I don't have Newton's tough JSON in my
usings list but I do have the dependency
on it in my project list so when I when
I type and look for that intellisense is
giving me that suggestion for that
unimportant type and so then tell your
now your suggestions list is way bigger
than it usually is and if you don't want
to see those extra suggestions you can
just use this filter button and then you
don't see any suggestions that aren't in
your list of usings but i do want to get
that suggestion right now and I will add
that and now you can see that
using has been imported automatically
into my file so does that automatically
for you as well and now I want to finish
this line of code a little bit and add
this variable and we have a lot of
different ways to generate variables
within your scope and and a new one that
we've added one central control dot is
to the ability to generate a parameter
and so I can generate this parameter and
it adds it to my methods argument list
automatically as well and if I look at
the next line there's a couple of rap
chaining calls over here and and these
chain calls I want to make it a little
bit easier to read so I can I have a new
suggestion over here to wrap this call
chain and this was actually a community
contribution to our open source
repository and around a third 30% of our
contributions or refactorings come from
the community so big thank you to
continue contributing and to help us
improve the product with those community
contributions and now I can now I can
see this list a lot easier and ice I
have some needless duplication over here
that I just can remove and make that a
lot easier cool and then let me go into
this file I did have some if conditions
that I wanted to take a look at and I
have this these two if conditions in
this if statement and I wanted to put a
breakpoint on just one of them and so
this was a community suggestion to split
if statements and so if I hit control
dot I can split this into two nested if
statements and that automatically does
that without any change in the logic and
that was a community suggestion and it
was a really high community suggestion
so we put that into the product and I
can do the opposite as well so if I hit
control dot on a nested if statement it
checks if there are any outer if
statements that it can merge with and so
if I accept that
refactoring it pushed puts it back into
a single line and so it makes the code
more compact
and I also have we've always had control
Casey and control ku4 commenting code
but now I can also do control ke / to
comment the line of code and if my
cursor is anywhere in that line I can
hit control K / again to uncomment that
line and if I wanted to comment a block
of code that's control shift / + ctrl
shift / comments that entire block and
again if I hit control shift / it
uncommons that entire block of code and
so those were two very popular shortcuts
in vs code and so we wanted to bring
them into visual studio as well and so
we did that and so if I go back up to
the top of this file there's a bunch of
using statements and they're all they're
all in unsorted and so it's really hard
to look at so I'm gonna use feature
search right now and that is control cue
so control cues are our feature search
is visual studio search and we've been
adding a lot of functionality and making
it a lot faster and smarter so if I
search for sort usings
it's giving me the feature the command
to sort my usings and you may think that
that's that it looks like a familiar
command but so and this is a story of
how feedback is so important to us we
had seen that remove usings and sort
usings where a command - commands that
were used together quite often so we
combined them into a single command
removing sort and then we got a lot of
feedback from the community saying that
wasn't the right thing to do because
there are totally situations in which
you would want to sort your usings but
not remove them because developers add
usings in case they want to use them in
the future not right now and so Visual
Studio was removing them because it was
thinking in the present well the
developers were thinking for future use
case scenarios so we added that command
back for sort usings and so sort usings
sorted those using statements and it
looks a lot better now I can also decide
where to place my usings right now and
so they're outside my namespace and I
can use ctrl Q again to go to my code
style options if I can spell right but
did you see if even if I spelled it
wrong it is getting that result so
there's fuzzy search as well so cool
and hit my cold style options and when
if I go down here I can use these code
styles for my entire project and so
right now they're inside my namespace
and I want to make it outside my
namespace and make it a suggestion so I
get that code style more regularly
across my whole project and accept that
so those were code style options and
let's move on so those were a bunch of
refactorings that we had and all our
code fixes and refactorings are powered
by analyzers and that's our Rosalind
analyzers and and Roselyn analyzers are
basically our dotnet compiler platform
analyzers and analyzers are tools that
give you diagnostics and error reporting
while you're typing so you don't need to
wait until you build to actually see
those errors and they manifest in the
editor as little squiggles so if you see
those little squiggles in your editor
then that means those are Roslyn
analyzers running in the background and
so if I open my air list this is where I
can see any of the results from my
analyzers and I have a filtering over
here so I can see errors warnings and
messages those are the three types of
errors that we have and there's also a
four type called hidden and and you
can't see that because well it's hidden
and but I can see the warnings here and
these two are over here and I can also
set the severity and change the severity
of the warnings using my editor config
file and that's a good segue into editor
config and code cleanup so for those of
you who don't know editor config is a
single file that lives inside your doc
into your in your repository and it can
it documents basically all of your code
style options and it can be a single
file or you can have multiple places and
it just affects everything that is under
that project route so I have my editor
config underneath my solution and this
is where it is and it it's part of my
source control as well so any changes I
make to it get pushed to my source
control and and so folks who are in my
team and and pull down the same
repository will be able to get the same
code style
options that I have in my editor config
so if I go down a little bit I can show
you guys the using directive placement
code style option that we were talking
about before and right now it's set to
outside namespace butts island so I can
bump up the severity of that to warning
and I get some completion completions
right here and those are basic text made
bundle completions and so I've bumped
that to warning and if I now look at my
error list I get I've seen I see a bunch
more warnings now based on my using
directives and so if I click on that it
takes me to this class and those green
squiggles indicate that these usings are
in the wrong place so I can hit control
dot and there we go I almost thought I
didn't sacrifice enough to the demo gods
today so I can move my misplace usings
and they will jump up there with and
squiggles will go away I also see that I
have a couple faded using statements
over here and they if I hover over that
visual studio tells me that these using
directives are unnecessary so I can hit
control dot to remove them or I can use
my one-click code cleanup and code
cleanup is this broom icon here at the
bottom of my editor and what that does
is it applies a set of fixes and
refactorings to the document that I'm in
and I can do that with the icon or I can
hit ctrl ke which is the shortcut for
that and so you may be thinking that's
just to my document what about if I
wanted to apply code clean up to my
entire solution well that's an excellent
question
so I'm can right click on my solution
here and do analyze code clean up and I
can run either of my profiles for code
cleanup and so I have two profiles and I
can configure those profiles as well and
we've seen folks use profile one for
some a very fast cleanup so it's a
lighter cleanup that they run pretty
regularly and then profile two for a
heavier cleanup that you can maybe run
before you push a commit so those are
code cleanup configurations and yeah so
I'm
looking at this warning as well and if I
hover over that it's ad telling me to
add a serializable attribute to my class
and this isn't an analyzer that's built
into Visual Studio it's part of a new
nougat package called Microsoft code
analysis FX cop analyzers and what we
did is we put a lot of the popular
analyzers into a nougat package that you
can just import it was too verbose to
build it into the IDE but you can import
that nougat package and I've imported it
and I have it right over here under
analyzers and like you can see all of
the analyzers that are part of it and I
can right click and edit the severity
set the severity of these analyzers to
whatever I want it to be and a brand new
feature that we've just added as well is
the ability to set the severity of your
analyzers from within the editor itself
so I can set the severity of this
utilizable analyzer and bump it up to a
error so that changes this analyzer to
be an error and so I can see that it's
now an error and I can also change the
severity from within the error list as
well so then that is pretty easy to edit
over here and you can see that any of
these this change that I made if I go to
my editor config and scroll down to here
then this analyzer has been added to my
editor config as well with the severity
of error so if I don't have that
analyzer
it'll add it to my editor config and if
I don't have an editor config visual
studio will automatically generate one
for me so you can see it's pretty easy
to change the verities and to change
your editor config and so be careful
when you do that because those changes
do go up to your repository and everyone
in your team gets those changes and and
they might get pissed if they start
seeing squiggles where there shouldn't
be any so that was editor config and
we've been getting a lot of requests for
third-party analyzers to break builds
but not necessarily show squiggles and
and run while while you're typing and so
we've added a project properties page to
called code analysis so if I hit alt
enter
which is which takes me to the
properties page for this class I can see
the code analysis tab and I have a
checkbox that says run on live analysis
and so if I uncheck that checkbox you
can see my error list will update so
that that error goes away so it doesn't
show up anymore it's not running on live
analysis but if I do build so if I run
my build control shift B it's going to
run my analyzers while I'm building and
you can see that that error came back
and if I look at my output in my status
bar the build actually failed so I can
use I can set my analyzers to run and
actually break builds right now and if I
don't want them to run on build and
break them I can uncheck this box over
here as well and so they won't run on
build all right next thing it's test
Explorer so we've revamped test Explorer
quite a bit in Visual Studio 2019 so I'm
gonna run my tests over here and we've
seen that customers have super large
test sets more than two hundred thousand
tests and our test Explorer limit
previously was only a hundred thousand
tests and so we had to revamp the whole
things for better handling of these
large test Suites so that you could
customize them and organize them the way
that you want so it's a lot easier to do
that and so while these tests are
running I can see that I can filter
first of all based on my past and
failing tests and so that shows right
here at the top and I also have a few
buttons extra new buttons so I can run
failed tests as well as a repeat the
last test run and so we we actually had
those commands a shortcut keys before
but once or twice a month someone would
come and ask us to add those commands
into Visual Studio and we were like
they're already there so we thought that
they weren't being discovered very
easily so we they got icons now and so
it's very easy to see them and use those
commands so you can also in your test
Explorer customize your columns so I
have a duration column right here and
maybe I was doing some performance test
before and so I needed that but if I
don't want to see it I can right click
and hide that column completely and so I
can only see I only need to see what I
what I want for that so specific
test and there's a new column called
target framework and we've added that
column for better handling of multi
targeted tests and so you can see which
target framework these tests are are
targeting basically and because as
dotnet is releasing more and more
frequently there are projects that are
targeting multiple different framework
versions and so there are tests that are
targeting different framework versions
as well and people were having a hard
time understanding which tests are
failing for which target framework
version and so you can see that right
here as well and then you can also group
by so you see this hierarchy over here I
can customize that completely so the
default is by project namespace and
class and if I just select that and
click out I can see a project namespace
and class and so these are the this is
the hierarchical group by and I can
customize that to be to however I want
as well so I can click out of this and
say I want to go by State first so I
make state that without one parentheses
and then class by 2 so it groups by
state and then by class and so I click
out and and I can see that hierarchy
over here and if I want to focus in on
some specific test so I can right-click
and add test to a playlist and so this
opens up a new window now and so this is
my playlist window and I can just see
those tests that I have selected and I
get all the goodness of test Explorer
and it's filtering in this new playlist
window and I can save the playlist as a
dot playlist file as usual and then I
can keep it but if I don't want to save
it I can just cancel out and it's
temporary and so it goes away and the
last thing I want to show in test
Explorer is is live unit testing and
live unit testing is an enterprise only
feature and what it does is it runs
tests in the background and so it's
always analyzing your code and with
every keystroke change that you make it
runs those tests that are affected by
that code and so if I go to a so it's
running a live unit testing right now so
I'll go to a file that has a little bit
more
test coverage and you can see that it
appears in my editor directly and so the
red X indicates that this line of code
is being covered by tests and some of
those tests are failing and so I can
dive into that a little bit in detail
and if the blue dashes indicate that
that that code is not being covered by
any tests and if I have green checks
that indicates it's being covered by
tests and all those tests are passing
and every code change I make it runs
those tests again and you can see that
it's being run right now for the code
the line of code that's being changed
and an important part of live unit
testing is sometimes I don't want to run
all my tests on live unit testing so I
have some tests and because this is an
application that runs an azure cognitive
service to generate Twitter sentiment so
every time I run tests that effect that
code it's going to hit an azure server
and if if it does that every single time
it's going to give me a huge a triple at
the end of the month and I don't want
that so I can skip certain tests when
live unit testing and I have that
category for that so that was all about
the revamp and the facelift of test
Explorer and let's move on to intelecom
so in Teleco Dizz visual studios foray
into artificial intelligence and machine
learning and we had intellisense for a
really long time I'm gonna stop live
unit testing and intellisense was great
but customers asked us could we do
something smarter than just alphabetical
instead of just ordering suggestions and
dot completions by alphabetical could we
be a little bit smarter and so we
trained an AI model on thousands of
open-source github net repositories to
understand context a little bit more and
so when we have dot completions now and
say I want to check this string for if
it's null or not I have my intellicoil
suggestions right here at the top of the
list and these star recommendations are
based on my context and they tell me
what is most likely to be used here and
so I get smarter suggestions at the top
of my list and I want to use is not null
over there and that was dot completion
and I we've also recently added
argument completion so if I want to add
in an argument and I hit control space
so it gives me these suggestions at the
top of my list based on because it scans
the scope of and the variables in that
scope to see what variables could be
possible here and so it suggests length
which is what I wanted to add and so it
becomes a lot easier to just hit control
dot control space tab and and that's
that's coding now I don't really need to
type anything anymore but but we're
making a lot of new changes and trying
out new things in a Teleco and one of
the things is this is a static model but
you can train in Teleco on your team
model as well and so you can build a
custom model based on your team source
code so that gives you a lot smarter and
more contextual suggestions based on
your own source code and one of the
other things which is brand new is intel
occurred refactorings and so if I'm
making a repeated edit so I see this is
equality operator and I don't want to
use that I want to use and is because
equality operator can be overloaded and
so I want to do the right thing and use
an is over there and so I think I have
that a couple other places in my test is
that here yeah so I see and is as well
over here and what I can do now is I can
go to my error list and I see that
Intelli code is detecting those repeated
edits and it's suggesting other places
in my code where those edits can be made
so if I click on that it shows me that
there's another line that's doing that
and if I hit control dot I can take that
Intelli code suggestion right there and
it changes that equality operator to an
is operator pretty cool right so that
was intelecom and next is lifeshare
so how many of y'all use lifeshare I
sure not a lot oh my gosh life is so
awesome I want to show you guys so I'm
gonna start a live share session right
now and live shares are Co collaborating
and co-editing experience final axis let
me accept that and so I can it creates a
sharing link that I can share with
anybody and since I'm all up here by
myself I'm just gonna share with myself
so I'm gonna pretend to be two people
and so life shirt collaborate lets you
collaborate with between visual studio
and vs code with anyone who that you
want to so I'm gonna open up my
preferred browser browser which is edge
do you guys see this new icon that you
got a new icon this week I think it's
really fancy but I'm gonna enter this in
the browser and start and it's going to
open up this prompt and the my preferred
editor for live shows vs code so it's
gonna ask me to open vs code and so I'm
gonna open vs code as well on this
machine and let's just assume that these
are two different machines I have my
guest which is on vs code and my host
which I created a live search session on
which is visual studio and so it's gonna
connect me to my full context in visual
studio through vs codons gonna load this
file tree and I'm gonna get full access
as my guest into into mic solution in
visual studio where my host is and so
it's joining that collaboration session
and once I get that I'm gonna get a full
editing experience I can debug I can
step through the debugger I get access
to my terminal and shared servers and
alright so and I can see where where I
am so if I am if I'm as my guest I'm
highlighting this code over here I can
see that in my host as well and see
which code is being highlighted and I
can even make changes in the code as my
guest so if I'm if I want to make some
changes here I'm gonna type in this code
and you can see in my host that that
code is actually being added real time
and I also get intellicoil completions
in my guest and this is vs code it
doesn't have any c-sharp extensions or
any actual any of the c-sharp language
services but I still get it because it's
it's taking it from the context of the
host and I can add that and completely
edit the code as well over here and
those changes get added into my host as
well so Leifer gives you great power to
collaborate we've seen people use it for
pair programming remotely as well as
like when if you want to ask any
questions to a remote teammate and you
want to get quickly let them
see your codebase and make changes that
help you out over there and because when
you're collaborating and collaborating
remotely you want to be able to talk to
the person we also have chat and calling
within the context of Visual Studio NBS
code so I can I can start a chat and I
can even start a call with with the host
from within my IDE so I don't even need
to leave my ID to do all of that
communication and that's a brand new
feature that we've just added as well so
that was that was live share and so you
can get up to 30 guests in live show
that's another thing that I want to
mention so it's used for multi multiple
scenarios as well where maybe a teachers
going to a room of students and you can
all like share in the code as well so
let's see we have some time all right so
let me go back to show you some preview
features so everything that I showed up
till now was in Visual Studio in the
release channel but you can also install
a preview channel and that's that's what
I have installed right now and that's a
separate installation of Visual Studio
that you can install side by side with
your regular installation and the
preview is updated every three weeks so
instead of waiting three months or so
for a new dot release you can get an
update every three weeks and those
that's that's basically at the end of
each sprint we release an update and you
can try out and play with the newest
features without really messing with
your regular production environment that
you're using in regular or you can use
your preview for all your development as
well that works too but so I have some
preview features that I wanted to show
you guys and the first one is related to
your tab layout you have not much you
can do here with your with your tab
layout you can pin the tab or make
different groups but if I open preview
features I'm gonna use feature search
again and type in preview and that opens
my preview features tools options and
these are these are the list of previous
that I can add or remove and if I don't
like a preview feature I can always
uncheck it and turn it off and the one I
want to show you guys this vertical
document tab layout and so if I hit OK
my tabs are now
vertically spaced on my left-hand side
and this was the highest suggestion
ticket in developer community for Visual
Studio 2019 so we got that into the
product and we have pinning over here
and you can quickly X out and it's a
very easy readable format when you see
those tabs one below the other and I can
right-click now and set my tab layout so
I can move that back to the top if I
wanted to as well and so we're updating
this experience and adding new features
so keep giving us feedback if you are
and tell us what you think about it we'd
love to hear about it and so that was a
vertical tab layout and the next preview
feature is go to base and so if I'm in a
in a class and I want to see I want to
navigate up the inheritance hierarchy so
I can right click and hit go to base and
the shortcut for that is alt home and
that jumps up to the interface that that
class was inheriting and I can that also
works for methods so if I go to a method
and hit alt home it opens up a window
because there were multiple methods that
it was overriding and I can select which
one to jump to and so I can do that
pretty easily now so that's go to base
the the next feature is actually in
intern contribution so this was work our
intern did over the summer and so that's
that's released now and so if I hit
control dot here I can sorry right over
here I can add null checks for all
parameters and I could do that one by
one before but now I can do it in a
single click so it adds the null checks
to check the nullity for all of the
check nullable non-tech parameters and
so that happens in in a single click
right now and saves me a ton of time and
so I have a bunch of XML comments up
here and so I was looking at these and
it and it looks like there's a lot of
styling options and those are some new
styling options that we have so if I
hover over the interface and click info
I can see there's italics and bolding
and clickable links as well that take me
straight to the documentation for that
interface and even bullets so I can add
all of the in the summary and show that
and quick in
but and even if I have an inherit a
Gover here I can get inherited classes
to also show up the same quick info from
the interface that it's inheriting and
it works for methods as well so any
override overriding methods also show up
the quick info from the overriding
method and so that was xml comments and
the last thing i want to show in preview
features is the documents base state
indicator and so this little option over
here she tells me that my document is
now in spaces and i can hit control w
just to show you that these are all
spaces and i can switch them to tabs as
well so whatever you prefer spaces or
tabs you can easily set that in the
document and if i if i change something
a little bit and i accidentally add
spaces then it shows me that this isn't
a mixed state and i can go back here and
switch it all to spaces so maintain that
spaces tabs consistency right there so
those were the preview features and all
of that you can install and get
immediately just today itself if you
want to install the preview and we have
some more time and so i'm going to show
you a sneak peek so this is something
that hasn't been released yet and we
haven't shown it off at all and I have
my preview instance of Visual Studio
here but I also have another instance
which is my master branch basically a
visual studio and so this we have taken
straight from one of our developers and
they've really excited to show you this
this feature which is basically
searching in remote repositories from
inside Visual Studio so you can use all
of your navigation go to files go to
find in files go to implementation code
search to some to search cross
repositories so you can search not only
what is local here but other
repositories that are online and so this
is a solution that I'm not very familiar
with but I would need to change the name
and rename this this interface but I
want to see where else it's being
implemented so I can
do go to implementation that's control
f12 and it pops open this tool window to
show me that okay so this interface is
being implemented here and there's a
columns for source and origin and so
this is a local symbol source so this
isn't my solution that I have open right
now and it tells me which solution it's
in but if I scroll down a bit
it also shows me results from a DevOps
search and so this is telling me that
this implementation is in a repository
that is online within the same as your
devops project that i'm in and it tells
me which repository it is and so if i
scroll down and open this it takes this
file and it actually downloads the file
and so this file is a read-only file
that's been downloaded from my online
repository and you can see if I hover
over it's in my local temp folder so
it's not actually a part of my solution
but just downloaded locally for the time
being and I can take a look at it and
let's say I'm interested in this string
typescript react and I want to I want to
find out where else it is so I can do
ctrl shift F find in files and now not
only my entire solution but I can also
search in my repositories as well and so
I can search for the string and all of
my repositories that are local as well
as online and I can also filter by file
type so these are only searching for CGS
classes but I can also add negations or
exclusions if I don't want to search in
specific folder paths or specific file
types I can add that as well so I'm
gonna search for CS classes hit enter
and it'll find in files and it's
searching in all the files online as
well and you can see that was still
pretty fast that's because we've
revamped findin files to be two times
faster for regular search and ten times
faster for pattern search so that was
findin files and let's say I want to let
me open up this file over here so I can
see how this string is being used and I
see that's being used here but I want to
check out what this method is and what
this method actually does so I'm going
to copy it and I'm gonna open ctrl Q so
that was ctrl Q was code search but I'm
going to
to actually search for get grammars
which is a method and I'm gonna move to
the code tab and now what it's doing is
ctrl Q is a code search that searches
for files types numbers that are local
in your solution as well as remote in
your repository so this was these
results our remote you can see there a
cloud icon in the repository that's it's
it's in and also the file that's that
it's in so that was so I can open that
as well and it's opened up all these
files and read-only mode for me I
downloaded them for me and so that was
cross repository code search which is
it's a brand new feature we're still
tweaking it a little bit and we'll be
releasing pretty soon so once it does
please give us feedback on and tell us
what you think
we'd love hearing feedback from all of
our customers and that was that was
basically everything that I wanted to
show you guys today
developer community is always open
please give us feedback on that you can
also give us feedback directly from
Visual Studio hit that little talking
person icon and and give us suggestions
or report problems I have all the
productivity tips and refactorings that
I showed you those links are also
available online and contribute to our
open source repository if you have a
chance to engage with the team there and
because all of that is open-source and
we're trying to be more open and
communicate more more often and more
frequently with all of the developers
using Visual Studio so that's all I have
for today thank you so much I'll be
around your questions